okay now just a quick note on notation
here before we start to actually
calculate these you can see it starts to
get rapidly tiresome to write area of
triangle blah blah blah blah etc okay so
what they do is they introduce a thats
quiet it's quite commonly used whenever
you're trying to measure the size of
something in magnitude or something
instead of saying out this whole wall
sentence here what they'll often tools
they'll put these two tall Lions next to
their arm whatever polygon one of the
neighbors of vertices they're up there
right you might be familiar there's some
of you all heard of this is absolute
value ok parlor isn't that is the same
idea same idea if i said to you
something like this right negative five
is an integer right it's got direction
as well as sighs so putting the absolute
values around it just means will tell me
don't worry about the direction just
tell me how big that thing is which by
the way is fine okay and if such where I
am everyone in this room gets to explore
complex numbers which are the square
roots of negative numbers the excited
they're really cool a really fun this
just means will tell me talking about
the size of this number it's don't worry
about what direction it's facing you
where you get two complex numbers
numbers could face more on just left or
right or up down they can face in
different combinations of those numbers
can be two-dimensional anyone all that
just to say where you see these two
lines right in this context what means
is ton of the sizes just in this context
that's area so we want to work out these
four triangles can you see where they
are on this diamond let's look at the
first pair acp and bcp can you see where
they are right ACP is this bottom
triangle Danya and bcp is the one city
on top of it right so these two together
make up the whole a hey BC triangle does
that make sense so let's work out this
pair together first ok now I'm going to
need to draw on this so if you haven't
already yet you need to draw this
diagram so maybe you want to you do that
now
now I want you to notice the kind of
information we are given down here in
terms of these ratios can you see these
ratios here right so we get a
relationship is what yeah amazing right
um we get this relationship between
these lengths yeah here's a P is P be
right and apparently they're wonderful
okay so I'm just going to say up the top
here that this is 124 okay that's not
the actual length these are ratios right
I don't know how long these things are
but I don't need to that's okay if those
things I want to fall right there's
lates that is what i can do is I'm just
going to move these off to the side a
little bit so we have a little more
space to work so let's put you over here
okay you can see right I can be a little
bit sneaky and try and think about the
properties that I just established
before and when you got power lines and
you got triangles that have bases that
are in particular proportions to each
other right so can you see this first
pair of arm his first pair of triangles
I'm interested in a cpbc Peter right you
can imagine them as being between I said
a parallel lines right watch I'll show
you a CP and vcp I'm just going to copy
this length over here right that's the
base between them okay we pasted over
here so you can see there you go it's
parallel bit now all i need to do is
move it up to about there okay now do
you see what I've just done you see how
to establish so you can see let's put it
another color you can see I've got this
parallel line here and this parallel
line here this is we've got the three
properties right which one is this one
do they share to the triangle share
exactly the same base it's gotta be the
same length right which they're not a CP
and bcp one of them has this base and
one of the has this vest is to see that
so property ones out however
property 2 is like this not when the
promotions are different like 124 okay
so therefore if I've got this triangle
over here it shares the same
perpendicular height as that's a bad
choice of color as this triangle over
here you see this it has to share the
same people perpendicular higher because
they're between this pair of parallel
lines okay it's just that I've got them
off at this angle like that so if i
wanted to i guess the parent the
perpendicular fight will look something
like this like so can you see it now
it's a bit funny this is one of the
hardest things about geometry that you
have to get used to see and all kinds of
different orientations I mean I suppose
you could just take the piece paper and
turn it around that might make of it
easier for you but again all i'm using
is the fact that there's a parallel line
there that i couldn't see right so let
me get rid of all that construction
there I don't know okay so now i can say
the ratio of let's see what was i climb
at a pc to be pc right sorry their ratio
rather not equals the ratio between
these two because they have the same
perpendicular height is just going to be
the ratio of their bases right which we
just established was 124 right it's 124
however hold on a second these two
triangles that we're just talking about
right if you put them together they make
up the whole thing get the whole the
whole triangle which has an area of you
can just barely see it 85 square
centimeters so this is one part this is
for parts how many two parts are there
in total there are fine so that means
every part is divided by five that's 17
square centimeters I think you'll find
if my divisions still okay this whole
morning so therefore right if each part
is 17 square centimeters here's one of
them so this bottom triangle here is 17
square sentiment and this top part here
will be whatever's left over red x 17
which is six
868 yeah 17 square centimeters 68 square
services so that's my first 1768 okay
now do you still think you need my help
and another construction to work out
what the other parents ABQ ABQ where are
you this is 82 here and a CQ here what
do you think what piece of affection you
use this time Thank You AC these guys
hey ABQ and Su you said what's that
other ratio that we've got its 23 right
to the three let's put it up here to 23
you see that one right to 23 again
conveniently away no it's not convenient
at all map is designed it so it'll be
that way to 23 means these areas are two
to three yes because again do you need
me to draw it one more time let's get
rid of this parallel loan let's put this
guy in instead there we go he's over
here okay do you see him now black so
these two train was here ABQ and a CQ
are between these two parallel lines but
they have bases in this ratio so
therefore their areas in the same ratio
to the three um it's still the same
their five parts aren't there so I guess
that would mean what are actual sizes no
this one is the top one which is to two
months or 17 to that's 34 Matt this
bottom line what's that over
51 right i can multiply by 3 cool all
right done so does that make sense it
was not at all obvious right when we
first looked at this diagram let me just
go back i'll rub off a whole bunch of
stuff so you can see if i go back to
whoops i rubbed off too much if i go
back to this which is where we began
didn't have that construction de nerve
that one we didn't have this here right
you look at this year like what where do
I begin sometimes you need to make a day
bro a little Messier put some extra
stuff of it before it gets better before
you can see okay there are some
relationships I can take advantage of
right because I think most of you are
probably thinking when you look at these
yeah no big deal okay not not that crazy
how does this relate to anything right
partly because when you see these you
see how they're all they're nice
orientations so it makes the property
very obvious to you when you look at
this you're like where isn't it saw it
somewhere in there I can't see it